♪
>> Laura: SPECULATION IS
BREITBART AFTER PRESIDENT
TRUMP SAID HIS FORMER TOP
AIDE HAD, QUOTE, LOST HIS
MIND.
THAT FOLLOWED THE PRERELEASE
EXCERPT FROM A BOOK THAT
CLAIMED BANNON HAD CALLED A
JUNE 2016 MEETING BETWEEN
LAWYER AS TREASON NEWS AND
UNPATRIOTIC.
MANY PEOPLE QUOTED IN THE
BOOK FIRE AND FURY BY
MICHAEL WOLFF ARE DENYING
MAKING CRITICAL COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OR HIS
STAFF.
BANNON HAS NOT.
SO LET'S TURN TO SOMEONE WHO
WAS THERE.
BANNON'S, YOU KNOW, DEPUTY
DURING THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLING CO-AUTHOR OF
LET TRUMP BE TRUMP
CONGRATULATIONS TO DAVE
BOSSIE.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
HOW ARE YOU DOING, MAN.
>> I'M GREAT.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Laura: YOU ARE NOT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> I AM HAPPY THAT OUR BOOK
IS DOING WELL.
>> Laura: SO HAPPY FOR YOU.
TREATING THIS LIKE MANNA
FROM HEAVEN.
BOOK IS NOW OUT TOMORROW.
THIS IS LIKE A PR -- THIS IS
A PR DREAM FOR EVERY WRITER.
THE WHITE HOUSE -- BOOK
WHAT'S HAPPENED?
>> THIS BOOK SEEMS TO BE
NATIONAL ENQUIRER ON
STEROIDS.
>> IT'S SENSATIONAL
JOURNALISM.
IT'S NOT JOURNALISM.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT IS
TRUE AND WHAT ISN'T TRUE.
THIS AUTHOR HAS A HISTORY OF
I'M DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT MY FRIEND STEVE BANNON
THE CAMPAIGN WHEN THIS
MEETING UNPATRIOTIC, FAIRLY
STANDARD MEETING ANYBODY WHO
IS INVOLVED IN A CAMPAIGN.
>> Laura: TREASONOUS HAS
PATRIOTIC MAN.
I HAVE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WITH HIM.
HE IS THE FURTHEST THING
FROM THAT.
I TAKE GREAT UMBRAGE.
>> Laura: HE HAS NOT DENIED
THE COMMENTS BUT HE ALSO
TODAY SAID THAT LIKE NOTHING
IS GOING TO COME BETWEEN THE
TRUMP AGENDA AND ME OR
BREITBART SETTING HIM ASIDE
THOUGH, WHY WOULD THE WHITE
HOUSE THINK IT WAS A GOOD
WING LOBBY MANY TIMES SO
FORTH.
WAITING FOR INTERVIEWS.
AND THEN BASICALLY HE WAS
GIVEN CART BLANCHE TO TALK
TO TOP AIDES.
I KNOW THAT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TOLD ME THAT.
THEY WERE TOLD BY ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS, I GUESS,
SPEAKING FOR THE PRESIDENT,
TALKED TO X,Y, Z AND ALL
TIEWX.
HE HAS TAPES.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT SAID
HE HAD TAPES TOO.
THAT JUST CAME TO MIND.
>> WOLF IS SOMEBODY WHO DID
HAVE ACCESS.
>> Laura: WHY THINK MICHAEL
WOLFF IS GOING TO DO
ANYTHING TO HELP THE TRUMP
AGENDA OR FRANKLY BE FAIR.
>> HE WAS NEVER GOING TO BE.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW WHY
THEY DID THAT?
>> IT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
SUCCESSFUL TAX REFORM.
>> Laura: WE NEXT SEGMENT.
>> I HOPE SO.
THE PRESIDENT JUST HAS THE
MOMENTUM COMING OUT OF HIS
TAX REFORM PACKAGE AND THE
GREAT BILL AND THE ECONOMY
IS STEAMING ALONG AND THEN
WE GET.
>> Laura: STEVE BANNON LOST
HIS MIND.
LOOK STEVE HAS HIS OWN
VIEWS.
I DID THE WHOLE INGRAHAM
ANGLE ABOUT THE SMARTS OF
DONALD TRUMP HOW HE OUTFOXED
EVERYONE.
GREAT POLITICAL INSTINCTS.
>> Laura: DON'T KEEP THE
NEWS CYCLE GOING ON A TOPIC
THAT'S NOT HELPING YOU.
I GET IT YOU WANT TO DEFEND
YOURSELF, I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT WHEN THIS BOOK, THESE
PEOPLE, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
WANT TO USE EVERYTHING AT
THEIR DISPOSAL, THE OTHER
CABLE NETWORKS ARE JUST
SALIVATING OVER IT.
>> Laura: THEY ARE JUST
DOING.
THAT'S WHAT THE GAME IS
ABOUT.
MAKE NO ABOUT IT.
IT'S TO FILL MICHAEL WOLFF'S
POCKETS.
>> Laura: I DIDN'T SPEAK TO
MICHAEL WOLFF.
I DIDN'T SPEAK TO HIM.
YOU DIDN'T SEE A QUOTE FROM
ME THERE.
I DON'T TALK TO THOSE
PEOPLE.
>> I DIDN'T SEE THE BOOK
YET.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ELITE'S
CRITICISM OF DONALD TRUMP AS
DISENGAGED AS UNINFORMED AS
NOW THEY ARE MAKING THE
ARGUMENT THAT HE COULD HAVE
NEUROLOGICAL PROBLEMS.
THESE ARTICLES ARE ACTUALLY
NOT APPEARING JUST IN
LEFT-WING WEB SITES EITHER.
>> BUT IT'S A JOKE.
THE PRESIDENT IS INCREDIBLY
WELL-EDUCATED, WELL-READ AND
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IF YOU ARE NOT.
>> Laura: DAVE BOSSIE,
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BOOK.
SO PROUD OF YOU.